Good morning. I'm Glenn Moore's, I'm an Associate Professor of Biochemistry and Physiology
at the University of Oklahoma Health Sciences in Oklahoma City. I'll be talking about the
utilization of ORD mode to write a specific kind of log file for thinking about writing
projects and particular research articles. I have stored a template for this file on
GitHub. You can find it at Moore's Lab if you go to the landing page and scroll down
to EMAX/LATED. You'll find a link to it.
I am a Structural Biologist and utilize extraterrestrial started feed and terminus structures of proteins
and nucleic acids that are important in human health. Our workflow is shown across
the top. We start out with purified material that we crystallized as shown by that elongated
rod shaped crystal on the left. We will mount that in a cold stream and collect diffraction
data with x-rays in the instrument to the right. That instrument will generate an image
like the one to the right. We see a bunch of spots. That's a diffraction pattern from
the crystal. After rotating the crystal for one degree, we'll rotate the crystal 180
degrees, get a full data set that will process with a computer. This will lead to the check
and wire map of the electron density shown further to the right. Then, on a far right,
we have a compared electro structures of two drug molecules from two different structures
overlap after a superimposing wild-type protein and mutant protein. We're trying to analyze
how the mutant was preventing one of the drugs from binding. These analyses can develop
better drugs. In this case, the drugs are being used to treat lung cancer. When I start
a new writing project, I will sign it a number. In this case, I'm developing a review article
about the detection of crystals in images collected with microscopes like the image in the upper
left. In articles about the utilization of AI to help with that detection of crystals. I
start the name of the folder with this index number. I store the manuscript folders in the
top level of my home directory, the E's navigation. Whenever I pop open a terminal window, I just
enter 0573. It tabbed on a complete name of the folder, and I'll be writing the appropriate folder.
I also use that index number to label the names of the files. I start every project with three files,
a manuscript, the log file that I'll be talking about today, and a annotated bibliography, which
is kind of like one on steroids. The annotated bibliography for the 21st century, not the 20th
century annotated bibliography, worked on as an undergraduate. I have developed templates, not only
for own mode, but also for other markup languages like R markdown and Latteck actually developed this
log file template over a dozen years ago in Latteck. I also have developed it for types,
as independent of Latteck. It's inspired by Latteck, but it's built, written and rust, and it's
extremely fast. So my writing process involves having the writing log at the center of the process,
is where I begin the writing project. On the right I have the manuscript, all its components
highlighted in yellow, and on the rough, on the, hopefully I said on the right, I have the manuscript
with all its components highlighted in yellow. On the left I have the annotated bibliography.
So when I start a research paper, I will do this after I have built up a strong idea from various
sources, and then I'll sit down and go through a series of steps outlined in the writing log to
develop that central hypothesis into a several paragraphs that are used in the introduction of
the manuscript. The rest of the manuscripts built around that central hypothesis, so the results
section will include experiments that address the central hypothesis, and it will exclude experiments
and nothing to do with it. Likewise, the discussion points address the central hypothesis.
So when I've done developing that introduction in, say, three or four hours, I'll have a outline in
hand, at least for the results and the discussion section, the outline will be detailed down to, at
least, the sub-heading level, and I'll move those components over to the manuscript on the right.
And as work is done to address that central hypothesis, the manuscript will be updated,
and also as an exploration of literature continues, new ideas will flow in to the manuscript
through the log file.
You've probably heard of another kind of writing log, which is more of a accountability tool.
A tool you use to hold yourself accountable in terms of your commitment to work on your writing
with projects. So this idea of a fault of carrying out this documentation is supported by
research done by Robert Boyce, Ethan of those academics who record their writing are four times
more productive of those that do not, and those that actually shared their writing with colleagues
are nine times more productive. This is sort of a case in point. This is a snapshot of a Google
sheet of such a writing log that I was sharing as part of a Google workbook, sharing it with
that three other colleagues. So I had the possibility of them taking a peek at my Google sheet and
that possibility I thought would be highly motivating. As you can see, July 24, 2023, I worked on five
different writing projects. This would not have been possible if it had not been for the
having five separate writing logs where I could figure out where I had started and where I would
report the day's progress before maybe taking a break and then switching to another writing project.
So that writing log helps reduce switching costs between projects.
My motivation for developing this project specific log that I'm presenting here is to support
clear thinking about the science I'm trying to do, hopefully leading to better science, as well as
accelerating the completion of the writing project. The secondary purpose is to enable working on
multiple writing projects in parallel. This is important to be able to harness your subconscious.
So if you work on project A for a few hours in the morning, say early morning, then late morning,
you work on project B, while you're working on project B, your subconscious is busy working
the way on project A. So as a result, perhaps the following morning,
while when you wake up or while you're taking a shower or commuting, your new ideas will emerge
for projects A and B, as a result of these background jobs that you have launched. If you don't work on
project A, then you're not going to get the benefit of the following morning.
The side effects of using this writing log are that it reduces the fear of forgetting and also
reduces the fear of losing momentum. These are two barriers to attempt to carry out work on
multiple writing projects in a given day. This problem of dealing with multiple writing projects
is one that is not discussed in books about writing. It's apparently a very difficult problem.
I think by writing log is a successful solution to that problem.
This is a overview of the writing log in or mode. So it has various components. I don't have
time to go through all of them in detail. But you can see its structure. We get this
summary view and you open up the file. If you have this in the header for a startup command overview
and then I just click on the heading, hit tab to see the contents below. So normally I'm just going
to go straight to the daily log, which is in this case it starts on line 944. I don't have to scroll
away down to it because of thanks to the support for folding these sections in or mode.
If I open up the drawer label preamble, I see that you can see that I have imported a number of
a lot of packages to enhance the format of the PDF file that is upon XB.
I have commands that are listed below at the bottom for providing a fancy header. This header has
the current date as well as the running title and the current page number and total number of pages.
So you can see in the center the header at the start page 2. We see the bottom page 1 where the
page number is at the bottom of the page. So this, these headers are very useful if you
have them to print out several log files and their corresponding manuscripts and take them with you
to work on them while traveling and variably the pages will get intermingled and we'll have to sort
about when you return home. So these headers ease that problem. You can see that the table contents
that begin the writing log is hyperlinked to various sections. In addition to the table contents,
the log file course will support various graphical objects like images, tables, equations,
code listings. I also added to the tech support for index, lists of acronyms, glossary, math
implementation, or literature cited. It takes no effort to add these in so why not have them available.
These features are also available in the annotated bibliography template which helps support
make that annotated bibliography far more relevant and interesting. So this shows a list of
four workflows that I'm going to discuss. Since I don't have time to go for each of the
items, so obviously there's project initiation occurs on day one. If I have a three or four hour
block at time, that's sufficient to finish project initiation. And then the daily workflow is
obviously what a person today to move the project forward and the periodic assessments are done
on a monthly weekly basis, generally on a weekly basis as the submission deadline approaches.
And then after you have received the gallery proofs and sent them back there are a few chores that
need to be done in terms of project close-up. And so this is an example of a protocol that could be
followed to do that. And an example of the kinds of more or less appendix material that could be
included in the writing log to help that this is done. So this shows a project initiation section
of the workflow. So I go through a series of sections that include advice about what I need to do
to complete each section. So the rationale section asked me like why are you doing this? Why should you
do this? Why not somebody else? Those sort of fundamental questions. And then I have
a drawer called label guidance that I have and that headline me or above, I have this no export
to keyword. So that guidance is not written out upon export to the PDF. Unless you want it,
if you want it, you have to remove the no export tag. Then I have a response to these questions.
In this case, the list of journals that I'm targeting for submission of this review article.
I have a plan B journal picked out in case the first choice is leads to the editors decide to
reject it. So having a plan D journal picked out is a decision can make at the time of submission
so that you're prepared to move quickly after the article is rejected.
This shows the daily workflow section. So each entry has a date. I sometimes annotate the
dated entries with a small phrase to highlight certain events. Within a given entry,
I have a list of accomplishments. That's sort of the bare minimum what I include. This just
demonstrates how relatively brief these entries are. They're just whatever distinct
accomplishments for me are listed. Sometimes I'll include the goals for that day. Sometimes I'll
always include the correspondence related to the project. So I'll copy and paste an email
into a quote environment from La Tech. And I have a snippet template for our generating these
entries. It will insert the date, for example, in the subheading. Then below that, I'll have the
next action. So following David Allen's, getting things done approach where you identify the next
thing that is begun. That may have come from a to-do list that's indicated below that.
And then beyond that, there's sections for writing accountability and then a reminder to go
about updating your central casting and org role that you have come across any nuggets for
knowledge you want to add to your org role. Then below that, there's a new another section for the
storage of additions to be made to the manuscript. Maybe they're not ready to go yet. So this provides
a spot for them to be incubated, a sandbox, if you will, where you have room to develop them further
before you, they're ready to be transferred over to the main manuscript. I also have a section
there too for the incubation of new ideas for new projects. So these, this kind of meta-data
or meta-cognition about the project are often stored and commented out regions are in comments
and like MS Word documents. These are often stripped out and rushed to submit the manuscript and
are quite often lost yet they can be invaluable. Not only for the preparation of future manuscripts,
but there can be very invaluable for responding to pre-teaks by reviewers.
So this writing log provides ample room for the safe storage of such information, such knowledge.
Then periodically every several months are weeks carry out a assessment of the project.
And so we go through a checklist for the completion of the manuscript. We also have a timeline
with milestones identified. And then course org has these wonderful tables that are very dynamic.
If you need a wider column to accommodate a new entry, it self-adjusts. So these are self-adjusting
tables on one reason why I was attracted to org mode because that coming from left tech,
we're working with trying to make changes to tables is quite difficult.
Then below that is a section to make assessments or four questions that I address about to the status
of the project. So one really good question is why can't you submit this project today? What's
going to do that back? And so other such existential questions are important to ask from time to time.
And finally the project clues out workflow. So this is in the form of a checklist. This checklist
in the main template is already included, but you could include it as from an external file.
Of course that checklist won't be only in the PDF when it's included in this fashion. It won't
be in the org file, but you can view that checklist by clicking on its file path. It serves a link
that will open up in a org buffer. The advantage of taking a modular approach to this sort of
appendix material is that you can update your protocols and updated protocols will be available
to all log files across all projects. So in conclusion this project specific log file helps
narrow the focus on one project. It provides space to harbor thinking about that project and it
helps support project initiation and sustain this momentum and facilitate its completion.
The side effects of using this log file for one project is that it dampens the fear of forgetting
the fear of losing momentum, which inhibits working on more than one project in a given day.
I would like to thank my friends at an Oklahoma data science workshop. We hold this workshop
every third Friday at noon, central time, by Zoom. It's open to participation by people from all
around the world. Send an email if you are interested in the applications of computing to
scientific research. I participate occasionally in these EVACs meetups and I have shared this writing
log with members of the UK research software engineer group through the MX Research Slack Channel.
My efforts are supported by funding from these grants. I'll be happy to take any questions.
[Music]